good morning John so you know like when
you get cancer and then you have to go
through cancer treatment and then you
write 90 minutes of standup comedy about
cancer and cancer treatment to prove
that you could still do hard things and
also that your brain still works and
also because you desperately want
something good to come out of the bad
thing that happened to you but then you
also convince someone to record your
comedy is a special so you need to
rehearse before you do it so you book
Seven shows in Southern California and
then since you're going to be there
anyway you fill up your days making
content with other creators and hanging
out with friends because you're trying
to prove to yourself that you really can
do hard things and you aren't that sick
anymore and maybe it's not like a wise
set of decisions but it turns out
surprisingly well and you book yourself
solid for eight days straight ending
every day with a marathon of 60 to 90
minutes of standup comedy shows actually
doing two per night on the last two
nights so there's a couple of reasons
why I've been thinking about YouTuber
retirement lately first as I was tuning
around doing podcasts a lot of people
were asking me about it but also because
of the thing that I was actually in Los
Angeles to do which was a bunch of
stand-up comedy culminating in filming
it for a special and here's the thing
when comedians like film their special
they tend to not ever do that show again
at least after it's released because
people have seen all that joke what does
that have to do with YouTuber retirement
when I was able to get somebody to agree
to record my standup special I was like
thank God first because like I needed
pressure to actually finish this show
like I needed a deadline and the day of
the recording the show was the deadline
and this is nuts but the last words I
said on that stage the second show that
was recorded we recorded two we're going
to cut them together into one I wrote
those last words on stage I mean I guess
I didn't even write them I just said
them so like the deadline for the last
line I hit it but barely but also like I
really desperately wanted to have this
project the standup be done I think this
is really interesting like I've created
in a lot of different formats before you
finish a book it's finished you finish a
song it locks in place in people's minds
and they even hate it if you change it
you do standup you record the special
you start working on new material or you
don't YouTube isn't like that and I
think it's a good idea to think about
why especially for YouTube Creator I
think there are a lot of reasons for it
I don't think it's simple but the way
that this works is kind of as if the
entire channel is one song and the song
doesn't end and like Tom Scott and Matt
Stephanie represent like two versions of
this Tom Scott is like the song ended I
made this big long song Here's how it's
ending and allog together it is a body
of work and like in the future Tom Scott
I know this guy he's not going to stop
being creative he will make other things
whereas theorist is another way to do
this where you just have the song keep
going without you and here's what's up
with regards to Vlog Brothers I think
that we are still doing it cuz the song
isn't over and is still delivering like
I think a lot of people make YouTube
videos primarily because it is rewarding
them in some way often times because
like this is their income Vlog Brothers
definitely used to be like that it isn't
anymore now we're doing it because it's
rewarding in other ways and like
primarily like a creative way it's not
really the creation of the videos that's
the inspiring creative part it is the
creation of the project of the community
of the things that we do but my main
point isn't about me it's about the
entire idea of YouTubers retiring which
to me isn't really YouTubers retiring
what it is is a person who has finished
doing something so it's a good thing
that there are more people who have that
freedom economically and also have that
freedom socially from Their audience and
that the Grace from Their audience to
feel as if they can do it because there
is a weirdness to it because a lot of
these channels including Tom Scott and
and theorist have this relationship with
an audience and so you have to explain
like like why are we making this choice
and respecting a choice that is being
made by a person about their life a
YouTube channel is not a person it's not
a person's life it's a part of a
person's life it's a thing that they are
creating and it really does feel to me
like creative Works used to be discrete
units like YouTube video is a discreet
thing but I think the real unit of a
YouTuber's body of work isn't a video
it's the channel and that's weird like I
think it's historically weird to have a
unit of creation that is decades long
and so I understand why moving away from
a channel is a big deal but I think that
retirement is the wrong word I just
don't think that we have the right way
to talk about it yet so I hope people
keep thinking about it John I'll see you
on Tuesday